[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down the final Last of Us
season 1 trailer the new look has just
released online and it's packed with
Easter eggs a big Cameo and callbacks to
the game that give away a lot of what's
going to be happening in the episode by
the looks of this this is really similar
to how the game plays out and because of
this I'm dropping a heavy spoilers
warning for the ending this will
probably give the game away literally if
you haven't played it so if you don't
want things ruined then I recommend you
turn off now without the way thank you
for clicking this now let's get into The
Last of Us episode 9 trailer
after all we've been through
it can't be for nothing
[Music]
there's no halfway with this
we finished what we started
[Music]
okay so throughout this we can hear
Elise voiceover which is identical to
these lines in the game
after all we've been through
everything that I've done
I can't be for nothing
this happens in a scene in which Joel
and Ellie come across some giraffes and
we get a major moment with them in which
we see some of the beauty in the world
this scene was just the pair taking a
breath from all the Mayhem they'd gone
through and it showed us that though
Humanity was on its last legs the rest
of the world wasn't this was a final
push to the fireflies and at this point
Jola Fidelity a chance to turn back so
they could go and live the rest of their
lives together as a quote unquote father
and daughter Ellie said they had to keep
pushing though and that all of the
deaths like Henry and Sam Tess and so on
had to be for a reason so they kept
going seems like they're pulling lots of
elements from that final part of the
game and the trailer starts off on a
highway like the chapter does at the end
we open with Ali looking at a deer
engraving on the wall and she's clearly
zoning out and remembering the time she
ran into David after Chasing one giolin
interrupts her and throughout this
section he does most of the talking
whilst she's quite withdrawn and clearly
realizing that this is the end gonna be
me after next Sunday because them
Channel views about a tank
now we see Joel in a dark gray shared an
alley in a red checkered one and these
are the clothes that the pair both wore
at this point in the game they're on a
long road which is how the chapter opens
and we can see a sign saying Salt Lake
which is where everything goes down he
casts your mind back to the end of
episode six then you'll remember they
came across a map of Salt Lake and a pin
with Saint Mary's written on it this is
Saint Mary's Hospital which is where the
fireflies are holed up at and this is
also a location where they can
manufacture a vaccine now we see them
moving through a tunnel and on the other
side of this you can catch a couple of
gray military trucks my guess is that
this is the federal quarantine camp that
they pass through in the game which is
where Joel finally opens up about Sarah
Ellie ended up passing him a photograph
of him and his daughter that she stole
from Tommy and is very much him
realizing that he can't outrun his past
the photo is summing at Tommy try to
give him back in Jackson but he refused
to take it whereas here he finally
acknowledges her death and moves on from
the pain this is because of Ali but the
pair don't get much more time to
together they're captured by fireflies
soldiers I'm guessing this happens when
the flashbang rolls towards them now in
the game they went underground into a
tunnel which is where they came across
the infected after making your way past
them you've found another tunnel which
should burst and water was piling
through which is when you try to get
across it you jumped into a bus that was
caught in the Stream but this came loose
and Ellie ended up having to save Joel
the pair were both pushed underwater and
in the end Joel had to swim her to the
surface she was unconscious and as he
tried to save her the fireflies arrived
and then knocked him out Joel and woke
up in hospital with Marlene at his
bedside and she told them that Ellie was
being rushed into surgery good news yeah
good news is that they're going to
create a vaccine but the bad news is
that Ellie has to die in order to do it
Joel was in escort outside by a guard
and he ended up going full on Rambo mode
and walking through the hospital using
it as a shooting gallery we see this
playing out in the trailer with him
walking through the corridors firing a
gun and this is him basically making
sure he doesn't we live through the pain
that he experienced in Sarah's death
Joel and rescued Ellie killed Marlene
and drove away which is when he lied
about everything that went down at the
hospital Ellie was completely deflated
and we then got a shot with her sat in a
car looking at her arm this pulls
directly from the game too with it
happening after their ride breaks down
just outside of Jackson so it seems like
it's all going down that way and we have
a couple of extra shots in the trailer
that we haven't discussed yet the verse
of these is a woman running through some
trees with NC have pushed against the
wall and an infected person scrambling
towards her now playing this woman big
Cameo is none other than Ashley Johnson
who also voiced Ali in the game after
tribaker's performances James were
following things up with Ashley playing
who's rumored to be a pretty pivotal
character according to the report she'll
be playing Ellie's Mother Anna and thus
this is likely a flashback to when she
gave birth to her little is known about
Anna but she was mentioned in The Last
of Us Comics called American Dreams we
found out that she was a nurse before
the outbreak and that she'd been friends
with Marlene for a long time an
important thing to bear in mind as well
is that Ellie's switchblade belonged to
her so we might see some stuff being set
up in this scene they're clearly trying
to make her resemble Ellie a lot too and
she even has a dark green jacket on this
is Samia Elise warned throughout the
show and it this might even end up
being another hand-me-down that's given
to Ellie now another thing that we know
about Anna is that she died within a day
of giving birth to Ellie I'm guessing
this is connected to the infected person
and this creature could end up buying
her while she's about to give birth this
could then give Ali a mutated version of
the cordyceps and it could explain how
she's got her immunity now this
flashback is likely going to be a Last
Crusade sort of opening where we see
Indiana Jones Eliana Jones getting all
the stuff that make her her she's the
only person who doesn't get infected she
gets a knife and this green jacket it
might just be that all coming together
now we also have a shot of Joe looking
worried moving to to a building with
orange sheets hanging up behind him it
creates a feeling of panic due to the
screen almost being Awash with red
lighting and I think it could happen at
two points the most obvious of these is
at the end when jio moves through the
hospital and hospitals having this color
schemes popped up in the franchise
during The Last of Us Part Two Ellie
chases a character called Nora through a
WF hospital and this ends up having red
lighting once they get further into the
infected zones could be something like
that or it could be before the giraffe
scene happens Ellie ends up running off
after spotting one and then Joel has to
chase her pretty much a nothing Burger
but it makes a great trailer shot with a
lightning and panic on Joel's face this
then leads into the last conversation
before everything goes down and it looks
like that's how it's playing out they
don't really show the ending scene in
this trailer but they do show lots of
things leading up to it so I'm guessing
that things are going to play out
similar how they do in the game if
that's the case then I'm very excited as
that's got my favorite game ending of
all time and it carries such ambiguity
with it due to us constantly wrestling
back and forth over whether Joe did the
right thing or not sure he saved Ali's
life but it was at the cost of the rest
of humanity and he also lied so there's
lots of complex complicated character
moments happening in these final few
scenes if it plays out that way now I
think the series has really knocked it
out of the Parker points and if they
recapture what made the game's ending so
good I think we're gonna have a really
brilliant episode plus we have the
Ashley Johnson Cameo it looks like this
is going to be an amazing way to close
out the season anyway thank you for
sticking with me and if you want to
support the channel make sure you check
out our last of us Inspired Real fungi
t-shirt which will be linked in the
description below helps us pay for
editors and it allows us to keep the
lights on so we can bring your
breakdowns like this every day if you
enjoy them if not then you can support
by just leaving a comment and giving
your thoughts on the trailer below we're
also running a competition right now
giving away the rocky 4K box set of
three subscribers on the 15th of March
and all you have to do to be with a
chance of winning is like the video so
make sure you subscribe the
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the teaser
we pick the comments at random on the
15th and the winners of the last one are
on screen right now save that to you
then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers he wants a males to watch then
make sure you check out our Brighton of
episode a which will be linked on the
screen right now lots of really good
stuff in that episode so definitely head
over there right after this prior to the
breakdown too all the team's done a
really good job on it so yeah cook come
on just give it just give it a click
give me a little view now if not yeah
see you next time you no solo Oh